it's a week full of outrageous and
over-the-line comments on the heels of
Roseanne bars hit show being canceled
for her racist tweet comedian Samantha
bee is facing backlash for saying this
Ivanka Trump who works at the White
House chose to post the second most
oblivious tweet we've seen this week you
know Ivanka that's a beautiful photo of
you and your child but let me just say
one mother to another do something about
your dad's immigration practices you
feckless
[Applause]
tight and low-cut and tell your father
to stop it tell him that was an Obama
thing and see how it goes okay
the White House respond in calling those
remarks vile and vicious B has since
apologized saying her comments were
inexcusable and that she crossed the
line despite the backlash celebrities
are standing by B Michael Moore is
calling it a brilliant rant and Sally
Field is showing support with a bolder
tweet of her own
there's also comedian Kathy Griffin
she's going after White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders for this
response to the Roseanne controversy the
president's pointing to the hypocrisy in
the media saying that the most horrible
things about this president and nobody
addresses it where was the apology for
Kathy Griffin going on a profane rant
against the President on the view after
a photo showed showed her holding
president Trump's decapitated head okay
Griffin tweeting B with lots of
asterisks do not come for me I did not
call you and for F lots of asterixis
sake take a cold reading class maybe you
won't stumble so much and if that's not
enough for you there is heavy metal band
no punk band punk band NOFX which has
been dropped from a music festival for
joking about the victims of the Las
Vegas shooting
okay so it's Thursday so a TGIF tomorrow
quite a week for all of these types of
things Greg let me just turn it over to
you before some semblance of sense like
bring us back to earth what's going on
well okay it feels like we're on an
outrage superhighway yes and it's all
driven by emotion which creates these
moments where people say things and then
those moments become opportunities for
scalps right and the scalps are then
because if I don't like your politics
I'm gonna get your scalp and vice versa
that leads to companies reacting in fear
firing people suspending people because
they see the the pitchforks amassing as
a mob but here's here's the thing I you
know Samantha bee apologized and I oh
and I believe you should always accept
an apology even though I know no one's
going to return the favor to me this is
what an apologize but I mean but I mean
I would say this for everybody here at
the table that people are coming after
you and waiting for you to slip up at
any moment there are organizations that
are paid millions that have sponsors
that just wait for us to screw up so
they can go after your advertisers go
after your livelihood your career so but
we don't do that like I would not say
that to Samantha bee I would not say I'd
say she apologized that's fine but I
know that there's an industry of knives
waiting for all of us and I realize the
only solution is that we have to do it
back to them so it becomes as mutually
assured destruction but I don't want to
do that why can't we just stop doing
this yeah when you say all of us you
mean conservatives yes on the right yeah
anybody approximation yeah yeah dad
that's true they're people who are paid
to monitor fox news all day won't you
just sit there and they wait for you to
say something that then they can create
a how about of I think that's probably
true I mean my goodness Greg mm-hmm the
C word is the gender equivalent of the
n-word it is extreme and it is
disgusting I mean you're talking about
looking for a person to slip up here or
there this wasn't a slip
I think frontal assault I know you miss
my [ __ ] that Trump you're missing my
point what I'm talking about is I'm
saying that I'm willing to accept an
apology even though no one will ever
ever accept as we see I would say the
way that we were all raised like that's
the right thing to do accept an apology
me yes accept an apology but let me ask
you Geraldo about this so when Roseanne
Barr did her tweet and her apology that
it was just a joke and then later on
said well actually I was on ambien and
tried to blame that this actually was
something I don't know if Samantha bee
intended or wrote into the script the
c-word but it obviously it was a
reaction from the crowd the crowd loved
it right which is is that why people
keep doing this well I guess I you know
Greg and I were speaking before the show
and he suggested that maybe she
premeditated this because her ratings
have been lagging I asked about her
ratings but to me this this is a larger
a larger problem
I think that particularly about Ivanka I
think that to attack Ivanka for the
purported sins of her father is
extremely unfair and you remember from
your tenure in the White House you know
the the kids okay now this is not a kid
this isn't a fully mature woman and
entrepreneur accomplished and she is
working for no pay as is Jared Kushner
her husband for no pay I think they are
both brilliant I think they have the
most underestimated people in Washington
and I think they are easy marks for
people like Samantha B to be snotty to
and and to attack and to try to tear
down and I think that this was a
absolutely premeditated how do I number
one because I buy into Greg's point
partially that this was premeditated as
a ratings look at me look at me but but
number two to use something this vicious
she knew does that mean the c-word it's
just like well it's it's like Roseanne
it's like there's some places you just
can't go anymore you know that we've
evolved past Jessie they were very quick
indecisive consequences for Roseanne
and doesn't look so much like that would
be the case for Samantha be know they'll
apologize and put out a statement and in
the media say let's move on she
apologized on to the next mark could be
Greg I think it's you I think but I
disagree with Geraldo I don't think the
c-word is the equivalent to the n-word I
think it's maybe down a notch not to say
it's not bad but I wouldn't equate what
Roseanne said to Samantha the gender
equivalent I said could maybe the gender
equivalent it's category I don't I don't
know how you can slice or dice it it's
ugly it's just not as ugly as the n-word
I agree she's looking for attention it's
almost like a cry for help the ratings
aren't good she's not a talented
comedian she's not on the level of a
Colbert or a John Stewart it's Samantha
b-list people call her she's trying to
make waves and the only way she can do
that is by being filthy and I asked the
brain room these people at Fox News that
do all the banking thing for you right I
said give me a list of other nasty stuff
she said I have three pages of some of
the most derogatory sexual slurs she's
used against members of the trunk family
some of these things I can't even say
about the president almost every single
one of them would don't be a tease give
us you know some of the worst stuff
she's reserved for the women Kelly and
Conway the B word F you hope it's
effing evil Sarah Sanders it's funny how
these female comedians whether it's a
Chelsea Handler or a Samantha bee they
saved the worst for the women in the
Trump world whether it's Melania or
Ivanka or Sarah Sanders because they I
think have more license as liberal
feminists so just go nuts on these
people you know a little something about
they're also really mad because their
girl didn't win sure you know and these
I feel like these comedians have gone
from being funny to just being angry and
I like your word your use of the word
snotty because we're watching just adult
Mean Girls all the time and I I think
comedians have a hard job in this day
and age because you have to walk a fine
line you want to be funny but you can't
be too unpolitical II correct or then
you risk you know did I say something to
offense
someone here or there so they do have a
tough job but comedy should primarily be
funny this isn't funny
this is just someone who has a problem
with someone and it's turning into a
mean girl before our eyes and seeing
what she can get away with saying I do
happen to think that this had to be
scripted this had people heard it this
had to this was a network decision to
release this I mean I don't understand
how something like this isn't an
off-the-cuff Matalan show everybody all
the way up to the top brass I'm sure
yeah networks have to make a decision
about how they're gonna handle this
stuff because what you don't want it to
look like is that they're selective
outrage and selective consequences
because then people jump and say is
there an ideological reason why some
people get fired and some people don't
so if you're gonna take a hard stance on
people and say we live in a day and age
where we're not gonna tolerate insulting
mean nasty stuff that's not funny and
it's just meant to make people feel bad
or be racist or whatever then you have
to do that across the board otherwise
you look like you're being selected I
think she's not going to be canned
because TBS doesn't think they're gonna
lose audience if you saw the reaction
everybody cheered
she may actually gain viewers after
something see but I'm with Chris Rose
and I think people would turn that off
see I would be inclined to accept the
apology but then it has to be if
somebody apologizes across the board
there has to be a policy here that it's
not like well one person says something
heinous and disgusting and they lose
their job another person at another
network says something heinous and
disgusting and they somehow keep their
job and then potentially get promoted or
zoomx that doesn't make sense
there's no but this is how you this is
how you make sense of this why there is
selective outrage goes back to what I
believe Charles Krauthammer said in the
80s the difference between left and
right the right thinks you're wrong the
left thinks you're evil so that that
defines the selective outrage meaning
that someone can get away with saying
something heinous about you because
you're evil right but if I say something
equally is disgusting about I don't know
any liberal they'll go like how could
you do that that's disgusting you know
you're you're a terrible person so it
said it it's that divide the they think
you're evil we think they're wrong that
creates this
culture that green lights everything you
can make excuses yes for the diskens
your nerdy you isn't a bad person right
because their mission their political
agenda is so righteous right that they
can allow for gaps and things like this
to happen in the in the in the goal for
what look I mean but the example is we
you mentioned the bad no no effects they
made a joke about the shooting of these
people and they said ah well at least
they were country music fans day 9 dead
people yeah yeah but the we know why
they did that because the assumption is
that country music fans to that liberal
band are nothing but racists rednecks so
the joke is ok because they are bad
people you see the point I think there's
a there's another point and it has to do
with timing I have made my share of gaps
and and some of them you know I've
looked back on to have my god what was I
thinking yeah the timing of your apology
is to me very critical for example if
you apologize as Samantha bee and
Roseanne did hours after you talked to
your PR person you've talked to your
management you've talked to your
executive producer you've seen an
audience reaction you know and it's that
I give that very little credit like I
don't I don't in any way a that doesn't
absolve the sin if you do it almost
immediately if you say oh my god did I
screw up but you hit the send button
that which I didn't do that let me get
that back I think that if there is this
on a near spontaneous apology where it
comes from the soul where you you are
your own policeman where you're your own
monitor and you're responding to what
your own misdeed or misfeasance then I
say okay right cut him some slack but if
it's a day later and they come on it's
not the point